this is one of the strangest clips uh
from right-wing media
from the reaction to the derek chauvin
verdict tucker carlson had an apparent
psychotic break during a segment last
night with a former
new york city corrections officer during
which tucker started
maniacally laughing in a way that was
reminiscent of jack nicholson's
joker from the batman movie and then
abruptly ended the segment and kicked
the guest off of his show
and much of what tucker does on on his
program in general
appears to be acting and fox news
lawyers have even said tucker does
entertainment he's not
like literal news but something about
this segment
strikes me as the real tucker tucker
seemingly unhinged
let's take a look at the clip tucker's
interviewing at gavin former new york
city corrections officer
the former corrections officer said
listen derek shoving used
excessive force on george floyd tucker
carlson just loses it look at this
the scene i i just think that it was
excessive and it shouldn't happen
and what guy who did it looks like he's
going to spend the rest of his life in
prison so
i'm kind of more worried about the rest
of the country which thanks to police
inaction
in case you haven't noticed is like
boarded up
so that's more of my concern but i
appreciate you coming on ed gavin thank
you nope
done thank you isn't that something if
you thought that the matt gates
interview was weird two three weeks ago
because of gates's behavior
it was nothing compared to tucker's
behavior last night
what do you think this is about like is
it is this that tucker maybe
senses that the chauvin verdict is part
of
their grip slipping away and maybe a new
era of accountability being ushered in
that would be great
i don't think that's actually why tucker
is behaving like this
was tucker planning on running video of
violent riots from minnesota last night
and there were no violent riots so this
is what he came up with instead
one cop found guilty and tucker is
instantly off his rocker it's very weird
and the laugh is particularly unsettling
but also kicking the guest off when you
supposedly run a show that's about
discussing
ideas even when your ideas might
conflict with somebody else's it's bad
enough
and of course this gets us back to the
really consequential piece of all of
this which is that there are
so many people who watch tucker
and they take him seriously and they
take his show seriously and they take
his perspective
seriously you and i might see this and
say
first of all how can anyone watch this
and react by saying
wow this seems like a good place to take
my my opinions from
but there are people who will react and
not think that that's a completely
unhinged person and for many people
sadly shows like tucker carlson's are
the only
input that they receive to form their
view
of what's going on in the world and in
the united states and that's a really
scary thing
now one one other note this isn't the
only time that tucker has sort of broken
like this
there was that incident it feels like it
was maybe a year and a half to two years
ago
when dutch historian rutger bregman
who's been a guest on this show you can
check out my interview with rucker on
our youtube channel rutger bregman was
interviewed by tucker
tucker didn't like the direction the
interview was going rutger
was clearly not laying down for tucker
carlson
tucker went nuts attacking rutger
bregman
swearing at him and then refused to air
the interview
we only found out about it because
fortunately there was a recording that
was released
so we were able to see it but between
that
and tucker's reportedly losing it at his
own country club on an employee or some
other guest
you can look that story up my sense is
that the 20 seconds i played for you
here
of tucker both furious with his guests
and
laughing maniacally in a way that seems
completely divorced from from reality
that i believe is the real tucker that i
think is the closest we get to the real
tucker because it matches the tucker
that we saw in what tucker hoped would
be an unaired interview with rutger
bregman
and it's the same tucker that is
described in his country club outburst
um i think that's the real tucker let me
know what you think
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
letting my audience
try it free for an entire month
curiositystream is a streaming service
offering
thousands of documentaries from some of
the world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals
and curiosity stream is just like the
netflix
for documentaries it's perfect for
anybody who loves politics history
science
just documentaries in general i've been
watching a ton
of curiosity stream i can watch on my tv
my phone my tablet
and one of the first things i noticed
about curiositystream
is that these are high quality
documentaries not
the cheap documentaries on many other
streaming services
i've noticed curiosity stream has the
biggest and newest titles
from the most respected documentary
filmmakers
my favorite so far has been what is
reality by david eagleman i've read his
books and the documentary
is fantastic curiosity stream is just
2.99 a month or
19.99 for a whole year but my audience
can try it free for a month
when you go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman